bravi a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti questo
video sono poi lei oggi siano dall adisu
just dance perché quest'anno abbiamo
fatto una roba
c'è rispetto agli anni scorsi quest'anno
proprio abbiamo natale proprio ce lo
sentiamo nelle vene nei capelli non e
cappellino abbiamo fatto un party di già
stessa a tema natalizio jacob una roba
che non veline anche mente proprio una
roba che manco ad hollywood la vanno
però la festa incredibile abbiamo
giocato i suoi divertiti abbracciati
tutti ci hanno un sacco di fan anche
alcuni di voi se hanno partecipate sta
volando vetri e grazie aver partecipato
c'è una mega tv e abbiamo giocato tutti
quanti e già test ruby da banking
soprattutto il sottoscritto che ha vinto
non è vero hanno vinto però ci ho
provato
oltre a fare questi balli sto casino
abbiamo fatto anche delle challenge che
vedrete appunto in questo video
e mi raccomando l'altro fino alla fine
per scoprire chi ha dovuto pagare
appunto la penitenza perché chi perde va
ovviamente doveva pagare una penitenza
provate a farvi un'idea su chi ha perso
solo 20 ci arrivate
provate un attimo voglio spoilerarvi le
cose però e guardate il video ragazzi vi
prego vi lascio al video buona visione
ricordatevi che l'unica persona che sa
ballare
[Musica]
grazie
ciao ragazzi allora oggi siamo noi e
faremo una challenge incredibile ha
venduto in quest'ora challenge devo
mettere le mani nelle scatole devo
indovinare che cosa c'è dentro
non ho capito niente
si chiama nichi box è una challenge
definitiva siete siete pronti
gli stream o mi sono sbagliato non la
faccio io lo riferisce la fanno loro
tutti quanti quindi oggi faremo la
mistery box nel senso che la fanno loro
e io farò dal giudice
sceglierò 5 di voi perché amo i tuoi
capelli ma non a caso non venga ieri
abbiamo scelto la ragazza alta la gara
sarà dura
io sì ci ho creduto fortemente erano
ragazzi devo fare un accorgimento lei è
l'unica che la maglia fa vigilia ma chi
sei e vinto il quinto grazie ragazzi vi
presento la mia squadra
giorgia è una donna
ryan françois par cavalli loro contano
per uno sarà
viola oggi abbiamo qui davanti delle
mistery box
vedo una ragazzina dai prof
siete in due ragazzi c'è una delle
orribili tirate fuori qualcosa di
decente praia de france fossili in due è
ancora un altro solisti ragazzi dai
comuni
i ragazzi e per me possiamo finire qua
c'è un odore terribile accusa mai
riprendi lei non me fatemi vedere che
cosa avete fatto alla camera non a me
non ricapiti hanno trovato tutti quanti
le cose tranne ryan françois è la luna
com'è possibile mi obbligano a dare il
regalo a tutti anche se non hanno vinto
la sfida però lo diamo perché perché
siamo delle persone buone oggi vinciamo
un po tutti quindi ragazzi poi però ben
avviene dopo uno solo siamo pronti
ufficialmente per le semifinali di
giovanni
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ciao
dai giovanissimi che aiuta a mano il
campione italiano picerni campana
ecco
[Musica]
vincenti
macché
jack
per il sud
sta lì sotto
ho sciolto
è un po sciatto
[Musica]
eh sì
[Applauso]
il cuore
di lei
[Musica]
lei non primo fiore vero prima però la
fiat ha mai fatto lo stesso ma non è
vero ma guarda 10.000 ok allora giocano
la finale la stabilità sconfitta mi ha
veramente abbattuto e oggi quel tempo
ero a casa mia
il mio televisore finché non riuscivo ad
allenarmi due volte di tutti quanti alla
vostra
e ora inizia ufficialmente la finale di
già spesi
[Applauso]
[Musica]
perché sì
no
a presto
[Applauso]
ha vinto ufficialmente
i campioni badare ai trovato titolo alle
patatine e oggi non riesco a capire
perché il mio compagno abbia fallito in
quest'impresa
dimmi che cosa è sbagliato il mascara 6
sbagliato ma senza ma perché non era lui
scusa perché non hai ballato per questo
è successo
tu dovevi che riarmi kharja teoria
quando uno fa schifo che sono io
una bravo deve portarmi alla vittoria ma
sono messa prima casuale figli siete
messi d'accordo
grazie al mio si sono messi d'accordo ma
essa va tanto bene non regge
[Musica]
dai ragazzi vi ringrazio per questa
splendida festa a tutti quanti tranne
sabrina che ha vinto quindi grazie per
aver perso con me grazie anche a già
stesse adesso ci facciamo questa
splendida fatemi nulla è mai come tutti
quanti stanno pericolosamente guardando
solo ed esclusivamente me sanno che c'è
anche tipo eleonora
male
[Applauso]
[Musica]
niente ragazzi continua mi sta piacendo
è troppo basso di miele vediamo il
prossimo video ragazzi sono molto per
brink